welcome to this video playing armor jian
again just played him couple of games
ago from the US and i'm playing a calc
on for a change let's like this
mysteries like with age 6 let's do
further tests game with that yeah
without age four and long castles
White's game ism is not too threatening
to yours okay but still its am not
entirely easy in the recent game someone
really managed to play 95 and sacrifice
on f7 I really yeah I really didn't pay
enough attention in this game I did got
it got very very hairy I should have
lost it okay let's see I what I play
route Queen B 6 to prepare a route to
the aid and then c5 yeah
an interesting trial trying to put a
piece on d6 it's not dangerous i think
at the moment 96 for example this also
95 attacking the important bishop so we
cannot really play that and what Bishop
d6 you can play but it's not leading to
to anything ok Wow III now maybe just
covering it ok group d 8 was the idea
anyway yeah I'm not is not entirely
great with guessing moves yeah okay i
can i can even capture but not a big
issue okay
Black is somewhat suffering from lack of
space but it's not not the end of the
world at all the night in fact does not
have a single square that it can go to
can only place he 52 to protect it might
be six of everything else fails and he
needs to play yeah yeah yeah okay and i
get d 5 or is there some better movement
turn at mine do I have some better move
let's pool our case also preparing 94 I
understand I understand but too late the
level okay
not sure that this is sure what this is
all about after d five half 95 and yeah
probably needs to do that but now
there's amongst others night c5 okay all
night c5 is not good playing g3
maybe just six come on let's let's go
that I go go down it's a it should it
should be ok actually Knight f6 King g7
yeah Knight g4 and then I go here using
using the pin and I'll take d for next
move
oh good lord I'm not done on time that's
a really rare occurrence okay take birth
the porn yeah yeah taking with the
rookie can take on your five with the
night so it's me for material point of
view is e it's equal but I have for the
passer and I think it's also just more
active like he would be fine i'm going
to get the B file or the C file maybe
you should take and play rook see one
but half d3m that's not helping at all
yeah I want I really want to activate
the rook on the B file so no reason to
hesitate I look B form yeah I push the
30 where's he going it's 94 check also
so I really have a good square can go to
see one but then I'll just play require
be two check check I'll take it the
night is hanging as well
I can I can just keep it I would see to
was also good but this should should be
should be enough
check
check
I know is taking that would check ok
it's not check not a huge problem
okay check let's see this is really an
uncomfortable pin I need to get get out
out of harm's way with the King and
maybe push here should really be enough
check check yeah come on keep it simple
it's not going to get the ball white
resigns yeah the song summer went
downhill quite quite quickly it's
somewhere around here yeah this is not
leading to much but it also shouldn't
lead to two white having problems yeah
does this I think is just about equal
white has some more space but it's
there's enough pieces exchange that it
shouldn't be a dramatic position for
back the way it was played we use
somebody got some some sharp play going
this is probably not good yeah and
finally that it is leading to leading
control yeah he's giving black already a
clash so we played this play doesn't a
less and less optimal run in a min oh
the snow yeah he needs to take here
ready after that will be seven black
asses winning yeah the comp agrees this
require before coming just like in the
game and there are too many weaknesses
there's a 204
and the deep on has too much that it was
quite nice thanks for watching